We can do the same with normal distributions, which are modeled by a special
probability density function. We're not going to go over the equation for this
probability density function in this course. But if you want, you can easily
look it up and see what it is. And that might be pretty cool for some of you
who want a little more information. But basically, since we have this
theoretical curve, we can model it with an equation. And using this equation,
we can use Calculus with a curve. But, we don't need to use Calculus, because
someone else already did. And then, they created a special table, so we can
always figure out the area under the curve between any two value. We're going
to use this table later. First, let's make sure we're all up to speed on the
normal probability density function and the area underneath. First, the tails
never actually touch the x-axis, they get closer and closer to the x-axis. So,
the x-axis is a horizontal asymptote. The reason the tails of this thoretical
model don't touch the x-axis is basically because we can never be 100% sure of
anything. In other words, we could have a value way out here, really far from
the mean, like five standard deviations away. But the probability of getting
this value or lower is very small. And it's equal to the area under the curve.
So, if we could zoom in, we would see this tail get closer and closer to the
x-axis but never touching. And then, the area in between the tail and the
x-axis, all the way to negative infinity is the probability of getting this
value or lower. We'll go more into depth in that in a second. And similarly, we
could get a value way out here. But the probability is very small. So
basically, what you have to remember is that if we have a certain value, let's
just call it x for now. That the area under the curve from negative infinity to
x is equal to the probability of randomly selecting a subject in our sample
less than x. And this is equal to the proportion in the sample or population
with scores less than x. If this probability is 80%, then we say x is the 80th
percentile. If this probability is 90%, we say x is the 90th percentile, etc.
If this is a little confusing, don't worry. That's the whole point of this
lesson. You're going to get really comfortable with using the probability
density functions and analyzing this area, and finding this area.